hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute einen
total beliebtes rezept nämlich gebrannte
mandeln und ich sage es jetzt ganz
einfach wie es ist ich bin mir zu geizig
die hoffnung auf der kirmes oder auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt zu kaufen weil die legen
die sehr teuer sind aber auch super
schnell zu hause hergestellt sind und
wir brauchen noch nicht mal viele zutat
nicht zeigt euch jetzt mal
wir benötigen natürlich mandeln ob ihr
die geschälte variante nimmt oder nicht
ist vollkommen euch überlassen außerdem
zuckerwasser und wenn ihr möchtet
vanille zucker und etwas zimt und jetzt
bin ich rüber am herd und wir gehen
jetzt zuallererst das wasser zusammen
mit zucker vanille zucker und zimt
hinein und dann kochen wir das einmal
komplett auf
[Musik]
und den zucker habe ich mit dem wasser
nur am anfang ganz kurz verringert sie
fanden noch nicht heiß war danach den
kochlöffel zur seite gegeben und ganz
eigenständig aufkochen lassen das ist
ganz wichtig jetzt kocht das ganze das
sieht man daran dass die ds
hinaufsteigen und dann gehen wir in
einem schwung unsere mandeln mit hinzu
[Musik]
jetzt sind die mandeln drin und ich habe
am anfang gab ja schon erwähnt das ist
völlig egal ob die geschieht sind oder
ob die haut noch drin es bei mir war das
heute nur zuverlässig geschälte mandeln
da hatte und jetzt versuche ich das
ganze bis der zucker richtig trocken
wird und das ganze auf höchster stufe
[Musik]
nach ca 5 minuten ist das ganze wasser
verdampft und der zucker wird so richtig
bröselig und das ist genau richtig ab
dem zeitpunkt einfach immer weitermachen
weil dann fängt der zucker an zu
karamellisieren
und er hat auch so ein knacken das ist
ganz normal und an der stelle geht er am
besten runter auf die mittlere stufe
damit euch auch nichts verbrennt finde
ich auch jetzt genau wann die popcorn
[Musik]
sonst habe ich mich ein bisschen platz
gemacht und ein backpapier hier auf eine
arbeitsfläche getan und es gibt einfach
den kompletten inhalt also alle mandl
nachdem sich schön karamellisiert sind
auf das backpapier und dann nehmen zwei
gabeln und ziehen die schön auseinander
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon die gebrannten
mandeln sind fertig sobald sie abgekühlt
sind und die halten sich wirklich wochen
lang also ihr habt da den ganzen winter
was von ihr macht euch am besten ein
vorrat ich sag's euch diesen so lecker
und die ganze wohnung nicht richtig nach
weihnachten also wenn du das ganze jetzt
noch machen möchte ganz einfach hier
unten in die infobox schauen da stehen
die genauen mengenangaben recht hoch und
runter wie ihr möchtet und dann freue
ich mich wenn ihr dem video ein dörfchen
nach oben gibt mir ein kostenloses abo
dahl es dann verpasst ja auch nichts
mehr
und ich freue mich wenn ihr mich auf
insgesamt ebenfalls abonniert da sich
nämlich immer alle eure tollen fotos die
mit zusendet beziehungsweise postet und
mich darauf markiert also bis zum
nächsten mal auf die sketche
[Musik]